dude I pulled a gun on Girl Scouts
trying to sell me cookies and opened up
the door and I was like stay your
purpose
yeah like I want to sell girls where's
the you're a [__] decoy [__]
[Music]
this video has also been circling around
this is a Colleen likes this one no
Colleen exclusive can we frame it like
that this video is not we're gonna look
at Colleen's top five videos this is
great security surveillance uh this is
at a barista on this side of a
drive-through and then this is a
customer in a car oh it's a truck I see
it doesn't do it oh let's press play
zip tie lasso huh yeah was it does that
co-workers like pulled her in you know
what I was wondering what the is it
those uh sexy Baristas like you know and
um it is not a bikini barista
because it was in Oregon I thought it
was that's why I thought it was I I
thought it was one it was in Washington
it's Auburn though right Auburn
Washington I thought that that's what it
was because oh yeah it is a
drive-through coffee stand and appeared
to try and kidnap the woman working
behind the camera it might be not to say
that hey it's because of what she was
wearing yeah or whatever right but I'm
just I was just curious because we did a
JK news about because he's like Bikini
Baristas and then most people don't even
exist it didn't look like a Starbucks
like from that angle it looks like yeah
but but basically there's these like
places where girls are like in bikinis
and and you can go and get like coffee
and some of them flash you so it's like
a strip show so you can go there and get
whatever's and what I was thinking is
like this guy started to fall in love
with one got upset and got obsessed
tried to take it to go and then
basically I think so I think it's one of
those like crazy situations that's what
I assumed and if I'm wrong
[Laughter]
yeah it looked like he had a zip tie
like the ones you have in your car yeah
the police call it a looped zip tie
device yeah but even if he gets that
around her wrist he still has to pull
her whole body through them yeah so
that's a tough I'm wondering how many
times has he done this and succeeded
because every time you catch [__] like
this I'm just like the way that they do
yeah
well the footage went viral as millions
of people saw this moment as the driver
tried to drag the woman out of her booth
and tie her arm Auburn police were
asking for any information which could
help their investigation directed The
public's attention towards a distinctive
tattoo on the man's arm which appeared
to say Chevrolet
too fortunately the approach seems to
have worked as they later announced they
made an arrest and paid tribute to the
overwhelming support from the community
which helped them find their
investigation Ford guys love this news
yeah let me see your arms I knew GM guys
were like this police said that they
were able to locate a suspect at his
home thanks to a number of tips and in a
statement said that they were able to
link them into the crime after searching
his truck a name has not yet been
released but the department is holding
off until the suspect has been formally
charged in the case wow so they I
couldn't I remember when I saw that they
didn't say it was a bikini barista
either I'm wondering if they're just not
saying that to avoid uh discriminating
against like almost she had it coming
you know what I mean like how they do
that yeah so it's like maybe they're
just because they don't want like a Joe
being like what was she wearing well
because one of the sad parts is that a
lot of those girls are alone in those
yeah yeah that's why give him a gun or a
[__] pepper sprayer so for real dude
like that must be hard to come and go
from your job that kind of looked like
it's at night I can't tell because it's
black and white but looks like it does
look like a evening type thing it's like
if you were doing bikini barista alone
like that's kind of scary really bad
yeah well I know it's not long alone
because there was somewhere in another
report that said her co-workers helped
pull her back in oh thank God do you
think videos like this causes more like
copycats or do you think this like
maybe people that would think about
doing this would be like all right I
mean I think for a guy who's planning to
do that it gives them a nice checklist
of what doesn't work yeah okay yeah he's
like all right yeah or they go check for
cameras first try a lasso next time but
that's every crime cover your tattoos
yeah yeah yeah yeah no Chevrolet tattoos
no brand names on my arm okay that blows
my mind though because like I just can't
even imagine thinking about going to a
drive-through getting some McDonald's
soft serve and grabbing someone to [__]
later yeah we're so short-sighted like
yeah I want a McFlurry and uh yeah yeah
and a kidnap McFlurry now MC [__] like
what the hell they doing yeah that just
it's just you got to be on a whole
nother level of crazy do you think
there's anything that like it like it
though it's like oh he's so romantic
he's trying to kidnap me I don't think
so no that's the first thing
do anyone find that romance we need you
here where do zip ties lie in your uh
chart like in the wildest of Home girls
are they zip ties in your love language
do any of our home girls really like
assertive dudes do you think he was
really like this is a weird-ass question
but like it it looks so clearly like you
can't do it that maybe he was just
trying to freak her out or just be
[__] weird I don't know yeah you got
to be like the rock to [__] that's full
a human being through a window into your
truck yeah in his imagination he thought
that it could be possible like after
even if he did get her out the window
she'd just be outside and he he kind of
wasn't slick about it like as soon as
the arm came out he was like you gotta
come and be like oh thank you and then
go but he found a Jujitsu expert in a
kidnap expert like you
actually does successfully get a zip tie
then it's not like the grip of his arm
and then two he might be able to like
drive you know what I mean and be able
to pull users that's just gonna cause
death but like imagine pulling even like
to a halfway point and then putting your
foot on the gas so that there's like
dude but even like with the zip tie if I
were to tie large arm with a zip tie and
to grab the zip tie yeah if he pulled
his arm back that's like no grip like
I'm gonna lose all that unless his arm
was also on the other side of the loop
yeah but she could like eat she can like
grab something she could pull him in
yeah if he stepped on the gas and it
separated the bottom half of her body
from the top half then he loses the
[__] part maybe she was trying to steal
his truck
you only get the titties in the face and
the upper body up yeah we're just
speculating yeah just speculate about me
I guess he's still up you know that's
what I feel like he might just be a
crazy dude and not really thinking that
through because it doesn't seem
plausible it does seem plausible that a
lot of these types of criminals don't
fully think things through thank God he
probably like got a double digit IQ
hey it could be a 99. you're talking 99
to 10. he's close and he might be like
I saw this one video of these guys in
France they beat this dude down they had
them at gunpoint but for some reason he
had this massive ass [__] rifle and I
was like what is he gonna do with that
but then the guy kept fighting back for
three minutes straight they're just
trying to throw him in his little ass
hatchback and they're throwing in the
back of the trunk and then um every time
he gets in his like one limb would get
out he would [__] snake out and start
fighting him again and then the guy's
just like recording this from his house
no one's coming out but it's like a
solid three minutes of him just fighting
and trying like just leave and then they
finally get him in the trunk they kick
him in and then they leave and I'm like
dude that's a that's like a real movie
kidnapping but how long it took blew my
mind yeah you guys see that video of
It's like a ring camera that caught
um a girl being abducted and her
screaming and then they just walk on
their porch and they just watch the car
drive by and they're just like
and they didn't know yeah I mean she's
saying help me help me help me and like
she's screaming and then they finally
take her and they drive off with her
yeah and then the people walk up the
people are in their house but it's all
captured on a ring camera or something
like that and you just see them walk on
like their porch and they just look at
the situation and it's like one of these
like just standing up yeah like what's
what's going on out here what's all that
racket I just have no faith in people to
really like step in or do anything they
don't know what to do it's scary yeah
yeah if you're not trained yeah at least
like I don't know but there's always
like the yeah there's always like the
immediately pull everyone try to take a
photo of the license plate you know what
I mean like without even getting close
type [__] right do something there was
there was um one I saw where a girl was
the bait on the ring camera she would
come up and then she's like hey um I
need some help whatever and then they
saw a guy like go like this and he was
like hiding and then I was like oh [__]
and then there's another one where
she actually opened the door and then
guys came inside they just like rush in
yeah they rushed in so it's so scary
yeah you just never know nah dude my
dumbass probably would like yeah that's
what happened to me I think I I think
I'm no [__] naive one that would just
not understand what's happening dude I
pulled a gun on Girl Scouts [__]
trying to sell me cookies and [__] I
[__] open up the door and I was like
State your [__] purpose yeah
you're a [__] decoy [__] he's like
two Thin Mints and a Samoa
they're like we're out we're always out
because I never have Samos leave the
samoas on the ground that's how you know
it's legit yeah you're like okay good
the Simone's not the best why do you
actually have samosas
why do you actually have someone that's
how you know it's fishy you're full of
[__] yeah and then the leftover ones
that one sugar sandwich one oh nobody
wants that one but it's always there
they should just sell some others
doesn't like dosi does he does it's like
the peanut butter one yeah oh those are
your bombs I like those ones too
thank you
[Music]